One of the things that most strongly differentiates modern from traditional societies
is the business of rituals.
Broadly speaking, modern ones have very few of them;
Traditional ones have a lot of them.
What is a ritual?
It's a periodic invitation by your society,
typically by its religion,
to come together with other people for an event that marks an occasion,
often of an underlying spiritual or psychological nature.
Perhaps it's the start of the year,
the birthday of a God,
a day to apologize,
or a moment to feel grateful for springtime,
or the love of now dead relatives.
And so you dance,
say some rather formal words,
eat an unusual food,
or wear special clothes.
And by doing all this,
you are, somehow, helped.
Purged in some way.
Helped to grow, transition to a new stage,
reconnect to an important idea, or guided to inner peace.
What marks out modern societies
is how ruthlessly they've stripped back rituals.
Largely because they get in the way of making money.
To generalize, when societies become modern,
rituals drop out of the calendar and the main focus starts to be private and work life,
and not much in between.
A key part of understanding our own times is therefore to grasp the history of rituals.
What they have been, where they've gone,
and in what ways we might be missing
them today?
Rome, 17th December, 150 AD
It's the first day of a three-day
celebration known as the Saturnalia: a
ritual festival in honor of Saturn, Roman
God of wealth and agriculture.
The Saturnalia is a time of ecstatic release
and exuberance. The Roman poet Catullus
describes the occasion as "the best of
times."
All the normal social codes and rules
are temporarily put on hold or turned
upside down.
Masters are expected to look after their
slaves and parents to obey their
children. Slaves can't even insult and
poke fun at their masters with complete impunity.
Important magistrate and public officials
wear colorful sometimes silly clothes and cones on their heads.
Your meant to shout "Io Saturnalia" at
strangers when you pass them in the street.
Married couples can have affairs and no
one is meant to be unduly upset.
Women can make the first move on men or sleep with one another.
There are orgies and you can gamble and
drink as much as you like.
Then after three days of fun everything
comes to a stern halt and order is
restored but life feels a lot less
bitter and oppressive.
The slave is back to his dinner duties
but the memory of having called his
master a shit lighten his burdens.
The mistress of the house is back to putting up with her boorish husband
but the two nights with
a hairdresser make a sarcasm and
dullness importantly more bearable.
Across Rome a great many people can't wait for the 17th of December to
roll around again.
Alexandria, Egypt, 10th day of Tishrei, 969 AD
It is shortly after the beginning of the Jewish new year,
in one of the thriving centers of Jewish life,
under the protection of benevolent Arab rule.
The Day of Atonement or Yom Kippur is a Solomon critical event in the Hebrew
calendar.
Leviticus instruct that on this date all
Jews must set aside their usual family and commercial activities
and mentally review their actions over the preceding year.
Identifying all those whom they've hurt
or behaved unjustly towards.
The ritual festival is kicked off by the blowing of the shofar:
a hollowed-out ram's horn.
Then together in a synagogue the Jewish
community repeat in prayer:
"we have sinned we have acted
treacherously."
They then seek out those whom they frustrated, angered, discarded
casually or otherwise betrayed.
And offer them their fullest contrition.
This is God's will,
and a rare opportunity for blanket forgiveness.
"All the people are in Fault" says the
pray and "so make all the people of
Israel be forgiven including all the strangers who live in their midst."
The day of Atonement has the immense advantage of making the idea of saying sorry
look like it came from somewhere else
neither the idea of the perpetrator nor of the victim.
Under the assumed eye of a benevolent God,
it allows everyone a chance to make a
clean break and move on.
Medina, June 12, 10 AD
It's the start of the Muslim holy month of Ramadan,
marking the first revelation of the Quran to
Muhammad.
As one of the five pillars of Islam
fasting is obligatory for virtually all
Muslims,
requiring abstinence from sex as well as smoking swearing and violence.
Fasting is believed to cleanse the soul
by removing from it
worldly concerns and focusing on God
alone.
It's admired as a way to teach self-discipline, self-control and empathy for those less fortunate.
Adherence to Ramadan will provide strength and
spiritual growth for the upcoming year.
Ramadan gives vital encouragement to an
enduring human desire:
the wish to start a fresh, reform oneself and lead a better life hence forth.
But rather than these ambitions being left to the individual alone,
Islam wisely creates a collective moment
to strengthen the will and it finds a
fitting physical activity to support
what is at heart
a spiritual endeavor.
Gazelle Peninsula, Papua New Guinea, 1652
A mother has come to visit her adult daughter and grandchildren,
for a few weeks in a village community of the Baining tribe.
Now it's time to say farewell.
There is sadness all around and the
mother and her guide head off through
thickly forested hills.
It may be a long time to mother and
daughter will see each other again.
The Baining have developed a special
word to describe the feeling that can come over you
when a friend or relative you love has
left.
They call it "Awunbuk".
Symptoms of Awunbuk include sleeping in, losing a sense of purpose and an inclination to burst into tears.
But the Baining have also developed an
accompanying ritual to deal with the sadness of Awunbuk:
The people who have been left are granted three days during
which they're not expected to do any
gardening or hunting.
Everyone is supposed to behave very
gently around them.
Then, on the third day the sufferers have to leave a coconut shell of water on the veranda of their house.
It's believed to soak up sadness and
with a few ritual words they then throw
the water out into the garden there by
purging their emotions and signaling a
return to active life.
The ritual of Awunbuk is similar to
morning rituals all over the world.
It legitimates what might otherwise be
a guilty or confused melancholy.
It gives sadness a shape and a direction.
It demarcate a time for it
and then gently creates a moment when we meant to
overcome it and rejoin the group.
Warsaw, Poland, spring 1798
It's the Jewish festival of "Birkat Ilanot"
which dictates that at the time of the
first blossom the community will gather
outdoors by some trees and flowers in
bloom to appreciate the beauty of nature
and honor the generosity of its creator.
In the company of a rabbi, Jews recite a ritual prayer from the Talmud honoring
the hand that made the blossom:
"blessed are You Lord our God, King of the
universe who didn't leave a single thing
lacking in his world filling it with the
finest creatures and trees so as to give
pleasure to all of mankind.
2,000 kilometers to the west, an English poet is also struck by the beauty of spring
and wants to express his enthusiasm and gratitude:
"I heard a thousand blended notes while in a grove I sat reclined" writes William Wordsworth
in the opening stanza of his
"Lines written in early spring" of 1798.
Both the Jewish community and the poet appreciate springtime
but the poet is not interested in ritualizing his feelings.
He is emblematic of a new age known as Romanticism which
believes in leaving people to feel
things at their own pace at a time of
their choosing.
Religious belief is in decline across
Europe and for many rituals are tainted
by being associated with a supernatural.
That's unfortunate even in the hands of
religions rituals have been guardians
are very important states of mind that
would otherwise be crushed or neglected.
A book of poetry is in the end a hushed
object in a noisy world whereas a ritual
protects emotions to which we are
sincerely inclined but which without a
degree of fabrication and structure we
might be too distracted and
undisciplined to make time for.
London, October 1834
James patterson, the governor of the Bank of England cuts annual, national or so-called bank holidays
to just four a year.
Only three years earlier the English bank like many
English businesses had been closed for 36 days a year to make room for all
sorts of traditional ritual festivals up
and down the land.
The bank's drive to slash holidays is typical of a hundred year long process that begins in the
late 18th century.
The industrial
revolution has made it deeply
inconvenient for employers to let their
workers take holidays to mark this or
that ritual.
The collective purification
of the soul is of no interest to employers.
It's something you can do in your own
time.
There are even suggestions to put an end to Christmas and Easter
which together cost industry of fortune.
Nuremberg, Germany, 30th of August
Adolf Hitler leads "The Rally of Victory".
700,000 people are in attendance.
People sing marshall songs are gonna blast from speakers.
There are banners of swastikas torchlight parades
and thousands of soldiers goose-stepping.
To engender a sense of fraternity flags are ritualistically touched against a
blood-soaked flag from Hitler's Beer
Hall Putsch of November 1923.
Hitler speaks for hours on racial supremacy, German art and architecture and
an international Jewish conspiracy
threatening to bring down the Aryan race.
Behavior like this hastens the modern
suspicion of any ritual behavior.
Collective activity and excitement start
to seem ever more eerie mob like and
out of sync with an individualistic age.
London, 30th of July 1966
96,000 people including the Queen of England
take their seats inside Wembley stadium to watch England defeat West Germany in
the world cup final.
32 million people are watching on TV.
The picture of England captain Bobby
Moore hoisting the trophy is
immortalized by statue in East London
while the ball is canonized in a special
museum in Manchester.
Rituals have continued into the modern age but they now tend to be around sport.
They're very limited in their ambitions
and lack a lot of the psychological
richness of religious minded rituals of
old.
Australia, 26 of May 2015
The 18th annual Sorry Day is held in Australia, when white Australians atone for the
removal of 50,000 children from
aboriginal tribes.
The day is a somber occasion for reflection with speeches from the indigenous Australian community
and politicians of all stripes.
However, the day meets with little public enthusiasm and engenders little change
no compensation is awarded and many feel
the day obscures the still prevalent
kidnapping of children from aboriginal
families.
Like so many modern rituals even once emphasizing important events in a nation's identity
national Sorry Day feels rather placid and in many ways token.
The part of human nature the craved and created rituals has not been
eliminated but it is currently in many
developed societies quiescent or
unfairly tainted by associations with a
less admirable sides of religion.
So a lot of what we used to do in ritual
ways we now do privately:
we have moments of carnivalesque
indulgence, we get drunk, have affairs
say sorry, purge ourselves and feel
grateful for existence.
But we also do so without guidance and therefore our behavior often lacks boundaries or is
half-hearted or colorless.
We also often just forget things.
We have very few collective appointments with important emotions
but perhaps we remain in need of rituals all the same.
Points in the calendar that help us in our endeavors to be sane and kind.
A challenge for the future will be to
create new rituals every bit as
convincing as those of old with the
proper resources of art, music and design
that will take some of the burdens
off us as individuals.
We'll have realized that being modern has not replaced our need for rituals.